let's talk about what are probably the
biggest protests happening anywhere in
the world right now
[Music]
farmers in india have been demonstrating
almost non-stop for months
they say new laws to improve agriculture
are going to help
big business but hurt small farmers
the protests even got greta tunberg and
rihanna chiming in
and lots of indian media telling them to
butt out some american swedish and
canadian citizens went on a tweeting
speed against him
so what is it about these laws that
farmers don't like
why does the indian government think the
protesters have it all wrong
and why is this about so much more than
just farming
[Music]
how do we feed everyone protect farming
jobs and save the planet all at the same
time it's something most countries are
trying to figure out
a lot of it comes down to choosing what
kind of system they want
in some places the farming industry is
driven by business
in others like the european union
governments subsidize agriculture
that's the juncture india is at right
now
for a long time farming there is relied
on subsidies and a whole lot of
regulation
it's one way of supporting the nearly
1.4 billion people there
given that about half of them work in
agriculture
but in india farming's been in trouble
for a while
it only accounts for one-sixth of
india's gdp
there are issues around land ownership
irrigation corruption and
unpredictable weather because of global
warming
and all that's caused a lot of suffering
in 2019
alone over 10 000 farmers committed
suicide in india
maybe there was a drought because of
climate change
or there was a locust attack or they
took a loan
and now they cannot return it because
the crops failed
so something had to change the
government and the farmers
both agree on that what they can't agree
on
is how last year the government brought
in three laws to modernize the
agriculture industry
one of the changes farmers are talking
about relates to who they do business
with
most farmers have relied on
state-controlled wholesale markets
called
mandy's where they're guaranteed a
minimum price for their produce
the mandy's then sell to buyers like
supermarkets
but under the new laws buyers can avoid
the mandy's and do business
directly with the farmers plenty of
economists and the ruling bjp
parties say that's an obvious win you
will be in a better position
to negotiate a better pricing than many
middlemen
the exploit is poor farmer and they make
more money
than the farmer themselves but farmers
and their unions are worried about being
taken advantage of that the mandy
markets will eventually disappear
even though the government says that
won't happen and that big corporations
will demand lower prices from small
farmers
who have little bargaining power what
farmers in much of
india fearing is that with the
government
gradually deregulating agriculture the
prices will plummet
and the corporations will be the price
sectors
rather than the government and
definitely not the farmer
there's so much more to these laws and
farmers have a bunch of other concerns
a lot of it boils down to a lack of
trust it hasn't helped
that the government rushed these laws
through parliament last year without any
real discussion
that's what the farmers and opposition
parties say so they want the laws gone
and they're sending a message
[Music]
a convoy of tractors from india's
northern states descended on the capitol
but they were blocked at the city's
gates so they set up three main
campsites
and they're huge
hundreds of thousands of people have
been living there for weeks
there is a rotating system where a group
of people from our village
will come to the protest sites whereas
the others
will look after the fields and things
have gotten
pretty heated
[Applause]
on india's republic day protesters
breached the walls of the red fort
one of the city's main monuments and
police confronted them
there
police have also been closing in on the
farmers campsites
using rows of barricades and barbed wire
the police is digging up
uh trenches and building fortifications
around the farmers protest sites
as though they are preparing for a war
but they've gone further than that
jammed internet access around protest
sites in new delhi
ordered twitter to block accounts of
farmers unions
and news outlets and charged
certain journalists with sedition over
their report
and then there's the media wars
especially after western celebrities
started commenting on the crackdown
and indian celebrities hit back
[Music]
hitting back gangnam tweeted saying that
greta
is a dumbo kid and a spoiled brat who
made a big blunder by revealing the
international plot to defame india
so this has snowballed into something
bigger than just farming they're talking
about people's right to dissent
police violence even the whole idea of
democracy in india
and some say party politics are making
it all worse
critics of prime minister narendra modi
think he's creating business
opportunities for his rich friends
then you've got the ruling party and
state media blaming the protests on
opposition groups
the banned terror outfit communist party
of india maoist
has infiltrated the farm protests they
point to these protesters waving a sikh
flag
as proof that separatists from the north
are involved too the poor farmer
feels that their land will be taken away
snatched by
these giant corporate but we have put a
safety net
the apprehension is primarily the
handiwork of the upa
members particularly the fiscal
opposition party i think the government
would like
nothing more than to see the protest
ending
but the farmers they will only move if
their
demands are met which is basically the
repeal of these three farm laws
those laws are meant to reform the
industry but they now seem to stand in
the way of any progress at all
what's missing is a whole lot of trust
but they have a starting point
pretty much everyone agrees that farming
in india needs fixing
so hopefully that was a useful primer
there is so much more in these farm laws
and plenty of politics playing out
as always check out our website
aljazeera.com for the latest news
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you